The first brother traveled to a distant village...
...where with the Elder Wand in hand,...
...he killed a wizard with whom he had once quarreled.
Drunk with the power that the Elder Wand had given him,...
...he bragged of his invincibility.
But that night, another wizard stole the wand,...
...and slit the brother's throat for good measure.
And so Death took the first brother for his own.
The second brother journeyed to his home,...
...where he took the stone and turned it thrice in hand.
To his delight, the girl he had once hoped to marry before her untimely death...
...appeared before him.
Yet soon she turned sad and cold for she did not belong in the mortal world.
Driven mad with hopeless longing, the second brother killed himself so as to join her.
And so Death took the second brother.
As for the third brother,...
...Death searched for many years but was never able to find him.
Only when he attained a great age did the youngest brother...
...shed the Cloak of Invisibility and gave it to his son.
He then greeted Death as an old friend and went with him gladly,...
...departing this life as equals.